التقرير لواشنطن الذي كشف عن تحديات
تواجهه تواجه الاداره الامريكيه خلال هذه
الازمه الصحيفه كشفت انه كلما طال امد
الحرب زادت تلك التحديات وفي طياتها ما
يطال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ومن بين
تلك التحديات ضروره ضمان امتلاك اوكرانيا
المعدات اللازمه لصد الهجمات الروسيه
بالاضافه الى حث الحلفاء الغربيين على بذل
المزيد من الجهود لتوحيد الراي العام
المحلي لبلدانها خلف كيير لكن الضغط
يتزايد فرئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في
مجلس النواب الجمهوري مايكل ماكول من بين
اولئك الذين يطالبون الاداره بالموافقه
على الطائرات المقاتله الان لتسريع الجدول
الزمني للتسليم والتدريب واظهر احدث
استطلاع للراي اجرته صحيفه واشنطن بوست
نيوز الامريكيتان ان 40 في المئه قالوا ان
الولايات المتحده تقوم بالخيار الصحيح في
دعمها لاوكرانيا وقال الثلث انها تقوم
باكثر من اللازم فيما اظهر استطلاع الاخر
اجرت شبكه فوكس نيوز ان اربعين بالمئه
يوافقون على رد بايدن على العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه ويقول 50% ان الولايات
المتحده يجب ان تدعم اوكرانيا ضد الروس
طالما ان الامر يتطلب الفوز ومع تبلور
الحمله الرئاسيه لعام 2024 من المرجح ان
يشهد الجمهوريون التصعيدا في نقاشهم داخل
الحزب حول اوكرانيا حيث شكك حاكم ولايه
فلوريدا
في سياسات بايدن قائلا انه ليس من مصلحه
الدوله الدخول في حرب بالوكاله مع الصين
او التورط في امور مثل الاراضي الحدوديه
او شبه جزيره الق